Oui, oui. Oui j'suis prêt à intervenir. On me dit dans l'oreillette qui est en fait une pile Duracell, que Trump est en danger.
*Musique*
Ok aujourd'hui on est sur Mister Président dans une veste de garde du corps , c'est faux c'est une veste de moto , ça dégage !
Mister Président c'est un jeu qu'on a fait il y'a des années et il vient seulement de sortir sur steam .
Est-ce que j'ai pas un truc blanc dans les cheveux ? Nan c'est bon , ce sera pas le top commentaire oh p*****n !
On est donc un body guard comme ceci
Hyper fidèle à ce qu'on est dans la vraie vie , Ah bah la c'est encore plus fidèle !
What ?!
Ah merde Trump c'est fait tué p*****n !
C'est pas grave cette fois on va le sauver les gars !
Oh on est trop chaud ! *rire*
Non pardon Trump désolé faut qu'jte sauve !
C'est bon il a esquivé la balle , on l'a sauvé !
Un p'tit replay sur cette action héroïque s'il vous plaît !
*Musique héroïque*
C'est parti deuxième niveau , Monsieur Trump vous êtes en danger
Si il continue à mourir comme ça j'lui vole ses cheveux et je les mets moi !
On en a bien besoin hein !
ARGH !
NAAAAAAN !
Oh NAN !! Mais comment on fait ?!
La vraie action maintenant
*MUSIQUE*
*Rire un peu nerveux*
OH !! Oh comme c'était beau !
Oh mon dieu , merci à tous , votez pour moi du coup , ce sera moins dangereux !
Oh mon dieu on va passer à travers !
Ah d'accord , attends mais c'est dur !
Maintenant !
Nan mais c'est impossible de le sauver , j'lui ai mis un kick !
Putain il va me licencier direct !
Oh j'lai sauvé là j'lai poussé !
Oh mon dieu ! Magnifique Magnifique , c'est la fin du chapitre !
Montrez moi comment sauver du président s'il vous plaît !
Ah d'accord maintenant on part carrément sur du , du 100 m haies quoi !
Bah voilà c'est sauvé !
Vous pouvez au moins me remettre une médaille du mériite !
Fils de p*te !
Mais j'viens d'où là ?
Nan mais le sketch mon gars ! Mais relève toi !
P*****n de body guard ! *cri*
*rire* Relève toi !
E****é !
On va passer direct comme sa mec .. YOLO !
P*****n mais plus lentement la chute !
Oh nan !
*pleure*
C'est pas grave , relève toi vite , relève toi vite !
Oh oui j'l'ai touché normalement il tombe , normalement il tombe !
Comme sa il esquive la balle !
Et en plus j'me la prends moi !
C'était pour ton bien Trump ! Maintenant tout le monde sait que t'as des spaghettis à la place des jambes !
Mais c'était vraiment pour ton bien
*bruit amusant*
Ok suivant !
Qu'est ce qu'il faut faire là ?
Des bombes ?!
What the f**k man ??
Monsieur le président , venez avec moi , venez avec moi !
Faut y'aller , faut y'aller !
Nan mais le gars il se met sous...
TRUMP !
Viens , viens , par là ! Ah j'l'ai sauvé là !
*Explosion esquivée*
*Explosion PAS esquivée*
Ah il l'a bien prise celle là !
J'sais comment faire , faut faire comme ça
BRAAH
Là il est bon , là il est sauvé là  !
*Explosion esquivée*
Oui ! Ah p*****n là on est chaud , on est CHAUD  !
Bordel de m***e , qu'est ce que c'est que ça ?!!
Mais pourquoi il mets des billets dans les ...
P*****n il a plus assez de billets quoi !
Allez relève toi , relève toi , relève toi !
OOOOHH !!
What the f**k ??
Je suis Clark Kent !
*Trump se prend une balle*
J'ai dit , que J'ÉTAIS CLARK KENT !
*Thème de Superman*
Voilà comment on descend des marches quand on s'appelle Clark Kent P*****n !
J'arrive Trump !
Bon là j'pense qu'il faut sauter comme ça
Okay là il se relève ...
On saute au dessus...
ON TOUCHE TRUMP
Oh c'est beau on le balaye
Bravo Trump
TRUMP TRUMP TRUMP ARRÊTE ARRÊTE
Les gens sont en train de voir qu'il se passe un truc bizarre entre nous !
Trump, notre liaison doit rester secrète !
LÂACHE ! TRUUUUMP !
Holala "Dead or Alive, un million de pesos"
Ce qui fait 1000€.. c'est peu cher pour Trump.
Ah ! Ah ! Ah ! Saute au-dessus !
Aller on y va !
Dans le sable ouais
Oh mon Dieu !
La barrière, et là , J'ARRIVE TRUMP !
*Se retiens de pleurer*
*Trump qui se prend une balle en pleine tête*
*Pleurs*
J'suis là !
Salut ça va ?
Oh ?!
On est vivants mon amour ! On s'en est sortis !
Le public n'est pas là bébé
Trump , ils sont là bas , ils sont là bas...
P****n , mais t'es con !
Mais nan mais mec.
Trump attention ! Trump y'a un laser sur toi...
Ah il est là haut , ah le mec , vraiment il s'cache plus quoi , il y a plus de limites, c'est un sniper mais pas trop non plus
*Rires*
Attend, j'pense avoir compris comment faire.
Nan !
C'est bon, du coup l'sniper tombe et il vise à coté
Attend, mais le gars il a trop d'équilibre
Il est pas tombé !
T'es , t'es censé TOMBER FILS DE P**E !
Mais tombe !
Voilà !
Mais pourquoi moi j'danse en premier plan ?
C'est fini ?
*Trump qui se mange un tacos en pleine tête*
QUOI ?!
Un tacos géant ?!
Voiiilà mon bébé
On est bien là
*Trump qui se mange un tacos*
Pfff !
Maint'nant !
OOOOHHHHHH !!!
Vite vite , 'faut qu'j'le r'fasse
HOP LÀ !
*Trump qui se prend un tacos*
*Rires*
J'ai retenu le timing, regardez moi j'suis une calculatrice hein
Trump, j'vais te pousser dans moins d'une seconde c'est pour ton bien
C'est pour éviter un tacos géant
J'ai mal à ma cheville
*Trump qui se mange un tacos*
Putain!
*Cri de Squeezie*
Ho il était beau celui là
On s'relève on s'relève Trump
*Cri de Squeezie*
Ho mon dieu c'est beau
Le troisième, le troisième, Trump
TRUMP LE TROISIÈME !
C'est bon j'l'ai sauvé, j'l'ai sauvé
Aucun tacos
ne tuera Trump
Vous m'entendez ?
Ok, encore un papier
P****n mais mec ça va être quoi là
va falloir jongler tout en esquivant une balle...
...et en appelant Mimi Mathy ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il fout là-haut ?
Trump Industries
D'accord, on part carrément sur un délire d'usine...
Heu... Avec des gens sous-payés
Alors comment j'fais, comment j'fais pour monter là-haut
Trump
*Trump qui se prend une balle dans la tête*
Nan.
Faut que j'aille sauv...
*Plaque qui vole*
C'est quoi ça ?
Video-game Jump-pad
Heeein...
HO OUI !
Mais nan, mais nan mais nan mais nan...
On va employer les GRANDS MOYENS FILS DE P**E
*Clin d'oeil*
Si vous avez besoin d'un bodyguard, j'suis là.
What the fuck ?
et j'sais même pas ou il est Trump
Ha il est là-bas,  il est là-bas
J'ai, j'ai cru voir un corps volé...
Mais Trump!
Mais qu'est-ce tu fais là, Trump arrête!
Ha il tombe dans le feu tout seul....
Mais il est con !
Pff...
Naaaaan!
Mais Trump!
Faut que j'le pousse pour qu'il aille sur le truc rouge
mais c'est impossible les amis !
Pourquoi c'est impossible
Parce que là, le temps qu'il se relève
Bah vous savez quoi j'vous explique en live à chaque fois comme ça on va tous le temps réussir
Mec ça fait une heure que j'galère et au moment que j'veux montrer pourquoi c'est impossible
C'est Possible, incroyable ! Alors il est où Trump ? Non mais mec
Il est au milieu de ces employés maintenant.
Allez allez allez poussez-vous !
P****n de m***e ! Mais attends mec sinon j'sais ce qu'il faut faire. J'pense qu'il faut passer du l'autre côté du mur
Et passer à travers le mur
Exactement comme ça *rire*
Let's do it !
*Allons-y !*
Ho c'est beau !
Alors houlala
Ha non mais le mec il tire direct il m'laisse même pas le temps de calculer
Ho c'est beau
Ho c'est beau alors ça...
Et sinon un jour on va le chopper le mec qui tire ou comme ça se passe ?
Ou on le laisse tirer heu... dix milles balles ?
Ho, ça commence à être dur là
Mon gars on l'a dévié in extremis
la le tireur il a raté six-cent (600) fois du coup
Il commence à être un peu plus fort. Ah le bras de m****
Me dit pas qu'il faut... non mais non...
NON !! *RIRE*
Oh j'ai cru qu'il allait se prendre la balle le con.
Je pense quand même si le garde du corps a toute intérêt de faire Ninja Warior
On va pas s'mentir. Allez next scene *Scène suivante*
*Rot*
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire encore ? P***** mais les gars.
Franchement je vais devenir...
Salut ? 'Faut faire quoi là 'faut qu'il l'évite ! C'est ça ?
On va le faire ! On sauvera l’Amérique !
*Musique épique*
*Shot*
Hoo !
Ce sauvetage digne des plus grands !
Trump, si je puis me permettre, mobilise des humains pour voter pour toi
Pas des statues, ça, leur vote ne sera pas pris en compte
Les amis, je suis fier de vous annoncer...
nous avons notre diplôme de gardes du corps.
On fait la super photo-cliché comme aux US
*Musique d'outro*
Sous-titres par Amine Brouk (et d'autres :)